hello everyone as some of you know
yesterday my channel hit 100,000
subscribers and as it's customary on
this channel
whenever I reach a certain milestone I
will show a make a Michael Tao game so
this game it's a very special game the
game is called not bad for a dead man
and if this rings the bell to you that
means you've been subscribed to my
channel well before my channel reached
even 1000 subscribers but I will get
back to that after I show you this game
this game was played in 1969 in Billy's
sea and McHale tile is facing a very
strong Russian Grand Master Alexey
sweatin Alexey sweatin became a
grandmaster in 1965 so already we could
say that he was an experienced
Grandmaster and he was also a trainer to
world champion Tigran with Petrosyan and
also his trainer in his World Chess
Championship match and he was also in
charge of overlooking young talents in
Moscow that way he was it say in charge
of overlooking the progress of none
other than Vasily von Schuch and later
in 1996 he became a world champion when
he won the world senior championship so
we could say that this game is basically
a game between two world champions and
also Alexey Satan was known for his
risky and aggressive play so again
between him and Michael Tao we'll
definitely you know bring a lot of
smiles to your faces so tall has the
white pieces and he opens with E 4 we
have C 5 by Satan the Sicilian defense
Knight to f3 d6 d4 see captures on d4
Knight captures and B 4 and a 6 now
sweating goes for the count variation of
the Sicilian we have Bishop to d3 Knight
to e7 Knight to c3 now Knight beat the
c6 Knight to b3 tall avoids the exchange
in the center Knight to g6 and we have
castles b5 now tile goes Bishop to e3 d6
+ f4 we have Bishop to e7 and now comes
Queen to h5 sweating plays a Bishop to
f6 as he definitely wants to get rid of
this knight on c3 as he knows tartare
will at some point push f5 and he wants
to eliminate one
the possible attackers thought it all
has so here tall plays rook a to d1 and
he's waiting for sweating to make a move
what style really wants is for sweating
to castle castle in would be a bit bit
too early here if sweating castles here
then comes a five you can't capture with
the night because well you would lose a
piece but on the other hand you would
also get checkmated on h7 so after D
captures only five now you get Bishop to
e4 attacking the undefended knight on c6
after going to c7 now you get f5 again
you can't move the knight because your
defenses will just fall apart so after
you capture it comes Knight to d5 now
attacking the Queen after Queen moves
you get nice to be for now there's again
an open attack on the Queen from the
rook and now your knight on c6 is
attacked twice so after something like
Queen to c7 simply Bishop captures and
black loses a piece so castling in this
position will be way too premature so
sweating eliminates one of tells pieces
better captures on c3 we have B captures
on c3 and now Queen to c7 still waiting
with castling we have worked to d2 by
tal with the idea that he wants to
double up rooks at some point and also
he's waiting for straight into Castle
here again castling would be too early
because if castles now then comes f5
immediately you don't really achieve
anything by playing he captures on f5 so
after Knight moves to e5 now comes f6
and now you break open in blacks
position G captures now rook captures on
f6 and after Knight to g6 comes at
Bishop to h6 and if you try to save this
rook although you really shouldn't try
this you you probably have to give up a
rope here if you try to save it then
comes Queen to g5 and then h4 h5 is
totally crushing so after this rip to d2
move Knight C to e7 first we have Knight
to d4 Bishop to d7 and now comes f5
finally he captures on f5 we have it
captures on f5 and Knight to e5 now and
here we have knife to e6 a nice
invitation for towels night if you don't
capture the night if you place
like Queen captures on c3 as your queen
is attacked and c7 for example you get
night captures and g7 with check King
moves and then let's say Queen to h4
Knight to c6 now defending that night on
e7 and now Queen to h6
and here black is falling apart you're
threatening to capture the d6 pawn there
really isn't a good way for you to
defend it if you play something like
Queen to e5 defending it you get Bishop
to f4 and this is this is just terrible
for black
so after this night the e6 move straight
and decided to capture the night so we
have Bishop captures an e6 you can
capture with the F pawn as its pinned
pawn captures and here we have g6 and
this is the perfect moment for you to
pause this video and try to find the
winning move for tile here as its it's
quite quite beautiful so I do encourage
you to do it for those of you who were
able to find it I congratulate you
you're an excellent player and for those
of you just want to enjoy the show here
top played Queen captures on e5 and the
game is basically over if you don't
capture the Queen you're down a piece
you can resign this game and if you
capture the Queen which is what Alexei
played in the game he captured the Queen
and after Tao played he captures on f7
would check here Alexis wit and resigned
at the game why did you resign the game
well it seems like luck has a lot of
options here but the truth is not really
if he goes King to f8 he gets Bishop to
h6 and this is checkmate
if he goes King to d7 then comes a very
nice series of moves but all of them are
forced Bishop to f5 this comes with a
double check from the bishop on f5 and
the rook on d2 King to c6 now comes the
bishop to d4 check and the King has
nowhere to go
the bishops are slicing all the way
there the rook is covering the D file so
black has to block Knight blocks and now
comes Bishop captures with check King
has to move now comes Bishop captures
rook again it's check from the rook on D
to King has to move and now comes again
bishop to d5 check King to d7 Bishop to
b3 check now King to e7 and now comes a
Bishop to g5 check
has to move to a fate now comes rope to
da check King to g7 and now comes Rock
to GA check rook captures and pawn
captures promoting to either a rock or a
queen and this is checkmate on the other
hand after he captures on f7 would check
if he play King to d8 now then first
comes f8 with Queen check rook captures
rook captures and now after King 37 now
get Bishop to a5 again with a double
check King to c6 and now again Bishop to
g4 the King has nowhere to go
Knight has to block Knight blocks and
now comes the Bishop captures King to d6
rook to f6 check King to d7 and now King
to f7 check and it's all over
King to c8 rookie actress Queen this is
with jerking captures Bishop captures on
a egg and now tal has tallies up two
bishops and rook this is just this is
just stupid so after he captures on f7
Alexis wait and didn't want to allow any
of this and he resigned the game and
this like I said it was a tournament
played in 1969 in Belize and this was
the final standings after the tournament
as you can see Michael towel won first
place with three and a half points
against ahead of second place Greg and
it's a beauty and Alexis wedding was in
third place with six points but there
are also some very strong names here
like guffawed Eduardo Bronstein David
román Jin Jia shrilly here we have comb
over at Mary Hart last Emile a lot of
strong players but tal really crushed
the field there so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and why I said that
the game was called not bad for a dead
man
it was a tom was in a hospital and there
were some news about Todd's death and a
news reporter that was watching this
game after seeing how tall demolished
Aleksei sweat and he said those words
supposedly not bad for a dead man as
some people thought that tall actually
died in the hospital
whether this is true or not it doesn't
really matter it's a very cool story I
mean I like it doesn't have to be true
but you know and until proven otherwise
we'll always always share it with
everyone and why I said that if it rings
a bell that you were a subscriber on my
channel before I reached 1000
subscribers is because I showed this
game already in a thank you video when
my channel reached 1000 subscribers why
I showed it again now that I've reached
100,000 subscribers well actually for
two reasons reason number one is that
it's it's an extremely beautiful game
and not a lot of people have seen it as
that video I made when I had 1000
subscribers maybe 4,000 people have seen
it and I would really enjoy it if a lot
of people saw this game played by
Michael town and the other reason is I
will put a link to the original video in
the description below so we can really
check it out how my channel looked like
when it was at 1000 subscribers and I
think it will be a great motivation for
those of you who are interested in
YouTube and maybe maybe are considering
opening a YouTube channel but you know
you have doubts about this about that so
do check out what my videos looked like
back then and I didn't have a camera I
didn't have a microphone or anything I
mean I did have one but it was just bad
and you know the sound wasn't that great
but I didn't care I just you know I I
want to show the world to me I make
Hotel game and I did it
so do check it out in the description
below it's it's it's pretty bad quality
but you know it's a nice nice comparison
to how my channel appears now so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and now on to the rules of the giveaway
and some information about the stream on
Friday
let's let's see the best way to put this
there will be a stream on Friday it will
start at at 1830 p.m. that's 1830
Central European Time also Croatian time
but pretty sure that doesn't mean
anything to you all the description or
the information about the giveaway and
everything will be in the description
below so don't feel you know too bad if
you don't remember everything
I will hold a tournament on leeches the
tournament will start some half
hour after I start the stream so the the
stream will start at about 6:30 p.m.
Central European Time and the tournament
unleashes starts at 7:00 p.m. Central
European Time and this time we will have
some prizes there will be a $500 prize
fund which will be divided on first
three places so first place will be $300
second place 150 dollars and third place
$50 and the tournament will be 2 min to
second two minutes plus zero seconds
increment and the tournament will last
two hours 120 minutes I decided not not
to not to give more price and money than
$500 because I didn't want to attract
too strong players just for the money I
want it you know everyone to just have
fun but also to make it a little bit
competitive and I talked about it with
with the people at elite chess and they
said that after the tournament is over
and it will take them some two or three
days to check out if anyone was cheating
you know they have to run it through
their algorithms and the prize money
will be rewarded to the winners after 2
or 3 days depending on when they finish
and the other reason I chose to plus
always because it will attract less
cheaters if I make a tournament with a
bigger time format like let's say 3
minutes or 5 minutes that that would
attract more cheaters and another thing
you have to play you have to have played
at least 20 games in both time formats
to be able to participate in the
tournament this will also not allow so
many cheaters to join as they will have
to first create an account they play
then play 20 games and then only then
will they be able to join which is
something cheaters don't don't want to
do so I hope we'll have a great great
tournament and have some fun
so like I said the tournament will last
2 hours Yann almighty will be joining me
on the stream and perhaps some other
players will see who will be able to
join me and what are the what are the
things I wanted to share with you yeah
after the tournament of course
we'll be doing some challenges you know
I'll be playing some games then young
young will be playing some games we'll
see and after that we will be doing the
giveaways so picking up the winners will
be will be alive and for the prizes for
this 100,000 subscribers milestone I
have chosen to give away two
championship chess sets like the ones I
gave up like the one I gave on my 50,000
subscriber video but with the difference
that if you are from a country and you
win this prize where there isn't a
championship chest set by you will be
able to pick another chess set because
there was a problem on my previous
giveaway as I said the prize is the
championship chess set and the winner of
the giveaway was from Croatia in Croatia
you cannot buy a championship chess set
so I had to import it and the the
importing cost was much more than than
the championship chest set actually
Worth's so it didn't bother me that I
have to pay the cost but for that money
I could have bought an even nicer set in
Croatia so to Championship chess sets
but if you are from a country that
doesn't have a Chess Championship chess
set to buy you will be able to choose
either if you want a championship chess
set or some other chess set that is
available in your country but it doesn't
matter if it costs a little bit more you
know so it will be up to you all in all
it only favours the winner so to
Championship chess set and I will also
be giving away 10 Amazon gift cards
valued at $25 each so only note there
there will be 12 prizes 12 picking up
the winners I will perform it all live
on the stream using the same website I
always use that randomly chooses winners
and that's about it I had planned
another another giveaway for you but
that that didn't finish well I ordered
some t-shirts made but they weren't made
in time so I will do that like maybe in
two weeks I have some nice custom made
t-shirts for you so yeah
I think I think that's about it the
rules of the giveaway are basically the
same as always
just write any comment on this video and
use hashtag towel so any video that has
hashtag Donnell in it will be
automatically entered in the Google
giveaway and don't write many comments
using hashtag towel because the website
will only use one of your comments it
doesn't matter how many comments you
write and if you really spam it then
YouTube will you know regard your
comments as spam and they will not be
shown at all so if you want to enter the
giveaway one comment about the video and
just use hashtag towel so I think I
explained this pretty well but I will
put all the information in the
description below about when the
tournament starts when the stream starts
all the rules of the giveaway what will
be in the giveaway so basically
everything and the link to make a tile
video against sweat and you can do check
that out and yeah I believe that's it so
yeah okay one more thing a lot of you
have asked me now that I my channel hit
100,000 subscribers that I should do a
Q&A video you know if you're interested
in anything feel free to ask me and I
will I will then answer it in a separate
video so you can use this video just use
I don't know let's see just use the
hashtag hashtag question seems
reasonable yeah alright any question and
in in like 24 hours or maybe 48 hours I
will search all the comments using this
hashtag question and whoever asked me
anything I will make a separate video
answering your question the question can
be about anything you know don't make it
about politics or something and
something something interesting I mean
you know regarding chess or regarding
God and anything personal basically so
yeah you select all to enter the
giveaway and use hashtags hash tag
question to ask me anything and I will
answer it in in my Q&A video so yeah
that's it
I do hope you enjoyed this game I do
hope most of you will make it on stream
and Friday and best of luck to you all
in Wii
the championship chess sets and the
Amazon gift cards so you can buy
anything there still aren't any Bobby
Fischer action figures to buy in the
world I tried to find some puppeteers
that could maybe make one but I was I
was unable to find any if there are any
of you my subscribers who are able to
make a Bobby Fischer action figure I
will gladly buy it from you to give it
away on my channel also a Michael towel
action figure will be also very nice but
then again I would enjoy having any
chess player as an action figure so yeah
that's it for this video thank you all
once again for for you know enabling me
to reach this amazing milestone of
100,000 subscribers I would like to
thank Neil Blanchard Lawrence Cuthbert
Alan Asbury and Petra Miraval for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thankful for watching and I will see you
soon with another classic game